un soleil de plomb et une plage de sable
fin difficile de ne pas céder à la
tentation d'un petit plongeon dans le
fleuve royal pourtant la baignade en
Loire est belle et bien interdite même
ici sur l'île de la mééie où le fleuve a
des allures de mer d'huile ouais je
comprends l'interdition tout à faitf je
nage souvent et je vois bien que le
courant voilà il pousse même avec nous
adultes on est on est poussé quoi donc
vous franchissez l'interdiction voilà
c'est ça mais j'avais vraiment très
chaud au pied peut-être pour des
périodes ponctuelles autoriser
effectivement les beignades après en
fonction du du temps du climat du
courant puis surtout qu'il y a une
présence pour surveiller euh les
baigneurs notamment quand c'est des
enfants quand on parle de la Loire on
parle bien d'un fleuvve vivant changeant
de débit de courant au final le tapis de
sable que constitue le fond de la Loire
bouge chaque jour exemple près du pont
Wilson hier ce ban de sable n'existait
pas ni même cette réserve d'eau sorte de
piscine naturelle au milieu de la Loire
une journée ça va très très bien se
passer mais le lendemain suite à ces
différents mouvements les profondeurs
peuvent changer le fond peut changer et
en fait on est rapidement dans un trou
ou bloqué sous un Tron d'arbre ou une
souche donc en fait on peut rapidement
se trouver dans 50 cm d'eau en dessous
comme on peut avoir des trous
régulièrement de 4 5 6 m avec des
différences de température et donc de
créer des chocs comme on dit enfin un
choc thermodifférentiel vous rajoutez un
petit peu de courant vous rajoutez un
Tron d'arbre qui n'était pas là à la
veille et on se retrouve bloqué au fond
et avec la force de l'eau ce blocage est
irréversible interdite par arrêté
municipal la baignade en Loire est
passible d'une amende de 38 € mais la
police ne dresse qu'une dizaine de
contraventions de ce type chaque année
préférant la prévention elle incite
néanmoins les habitants à leur signaler
la présence de baigneurs imprudents dans
le fleuve notamment lorsqu'il s'agit de
groupe d'adolescents ou d'enfants
situation fréquente durant les grandes
vacances